in our series school matters we're
looking at how the pandemic is affecting
classroom results about two-thirds of
american students are using
some form of remote learning but some
new academic performance numbers suggest
the disruption to in-person education
is taking a heavy toll on many of them
meg oliver spoke to families in
different states and shows us
how they're coping meg good morning
anthony good morning students here in
montclair new jersey haven't seen the
inside of a classroom in more than
eight months but across the country
about 40 percent of districts fall into
that category
and the students grades tell a sad story
ericia oates is a single mom of four
children in east tampa florida
when he gets sick it's a whole other
level she chose all remote to protect
the health of her oldest son who suffers
from epilepsy
but her fifteen-year-old daughter is
struggling
has she ever failed a grade before she
has not
and this fall she made a d the last nine
weeks on
hp world history and she was freaking
out
that has never happened before how is
that affecting you it stressing me out
as well because my daughter has never
struggled
and to have her feel like she's being
defeated
is a problem it's a problem happening to
students around the country
in houston one of the largest school
districts in the nation
the number of students with failing
grades is exploding
during the fall of this year 42 percent
of students received
one or more f's in the first grading
period which was
100 percent virtual last year only 26
percent
fell into that category these children
are struggling to read struggling to do
math
christina quintero has two children in
houston school district
she says her first grade daughter feels
defeated
is she getting down on herself oh she's
very
critical very critical in her academics
because she just wants to do better she
wants to be able to
show that to her teacher and be proud of
herself we know that there has been a
significant loss of learning
but i tell you we're less concerned
about that than we are
about the social emotional factors dan
dominic
is the executive director of the
american association of school
administrators
and served as a superintendent for
nearly 30 years
we're seeing an increase in the stress
that students are feeling the
the emotional impact that this is having
on them we're carefully tracking suicide
rates
which is a major factor so we are more
concerned right now about the emotional
well-being of our students than we are
about their academic
loss between march and october of this
year
numbers from the cdc show mental health
related
emergency room visits increased nearly
28 percent for children
ages 5 to 17 compared to the same period
last year and grades in north carolina
paint a bleak picture as well
in wilson county 46 percent of students
in grades 3 through 12
fell to class this fall while learning
virtually that is more than
double from the same period last year we
made an early decision to award
incompletes to students who are trying
to make progress what weren't where they
were supposed to be
because it sends a signal to finish as
opposed to an f
in cleveland 42 percent of the students
live below the poverty line
superintendent eric gordon says 20
percent of cleveland metro students
had incompletes in the first marking
period
is it fair to have traditional grading
in all remote learning
by using an abc or incomplete strategy
we're actually moving towards does the
student know what we want them to know
before we move on
or do they need to finish that learning
so i think it's just another opportunity
for us to question
our past strategies and think about how
to make a better system when we come out
of this pandemic if things don't improve
for alicia's daughter she will send her
back to class for in person
and sent her son to live with her mom
the last time my son had a seizure
he he almost didn't make it so it's more
of
life or death for him because the
numbers in hillsborough county are
rising
so for safety that's one of the options
that we've been wearing
as parents face these difficult
decisions cleveland superintendent told
me we're unfairly measuring students
during a time
no one could have imagined they're
already discussing ways to close the gap
post pandemic whether that involves
summer school
night classes or even weekend camps tony
it's going to take a lot meg thank you
very much